oh wait wait what that's nuts oh I feel
like I'm just more confused now let's
take a look at how they achieve such a
high level of quality
thanks to Bose for sponsoring this video
stick around to find out about the Bose
headphones 700 hey guys welcome back to
another episode of visual effects
artists react we are here once again in
the studio during the pandemic socially
isolated in distances also can I just
quickly point out that we are watching
this stuff on the TV that's broken way
over there we're gonna west nude broke
thank you guys
moving onwards also this is extra proof
that even behind the camera everyone
staying safe alright you guys are you
guys ready to watch these clips yes
ready let's dive in alright first clip
let's see it
so His Dark Materials is a show that
just came out on HBO it's based on the
Golden Compass series by Philip Pullman
every person in this world has a demon
which is an animal companion it's
another human soul that's manifested in
an animal it is a whole bunch of magical
fantasy rules around all this it's like
Pokemon basically so in this universe
already has a Pokemon but the crazy
thing is they decided to go with the the
CG animal or outfits HBO series and
there's not a single moment in the show
where the CG falters for the animals
they look good
100% of the time it's one thing for like
a TV show to try to do CG
sometimes I look good sometimes it
doesn't in this case HBO just knocked it
out of the park I think they've learned
a lot of lessons from Game of Thrones in
terms of how good your VFX can look and
they kind of want this to be the next
Game of Thrones so her demon hasn't
settled yet just shape-shifted into a
new animal you see that the monkey grab
the table there's a grab the cat really
yeah whoop whoa he slips a little bit
like you see it you know shifters yeah
they're really interacting with their
environment there
the rendering is good the camera works
good animations great so I just want
point a couple things out here that just
really stand out to me for the quality
here first off the shadow of the monkey
on the carpet so there's you know big
area lights off to the side of the
windows and with an area light when the
shadows right next to the thing casting
the shadow it will be sharp and the
further away it gets it gets softer and
they're nailing that look here with a
monkey shadow on the ground and the only
thing that's really really well done is
the the color matching the color
tonality of the CG is matching the
tonality of what they filmed really
really well everything from like the
quality like the light shining off the
fur to like how the kitten the colors
kind of mapped themselves from light to
dark across the scene the warmth and all
that kind of stuff it just looks great
and that transition that more from
animal to animal is also really well
done it doesn't read his fake like even
get there like momentum transfer of like
the ferret morphing into the cat so we
can marvel at how well done these
animals are but let's take a look at how
they achieve such a high level of
quality and in the end they decided that
on the day we have a series of puppets
oh wait wait what oh okay okay I see I
see it's so cool so those puppets are
really interesting because they're not
exactly there for photographic reference
maybe the heads are but the bodies are
not they're there for animation
reference so they're there they've got
like exaggerated discs on them so that
you can clearly see the orientation of
different limbs and you know dealing
with child actors like here here's a
little companion to act against and look
at surely they're doing a plate without
any of that in there right I mean I I'm
sure I'm sure the first the first ones
just for a reference and they just do it
again without it when you're filming
live-action plates that you're then
going to be dropping VFX on to you're
locked in to what you film you know
somebody's walking and they're looking
down they talk about the creature you'd
easily get a shot where you accidentally
frame the creature out because you're
yours up a little bit too much you're
looking in the wrong spot and so when
you're going to be adding a CG object
it's kind of a risky move so in this
case you're having a puppet on set to
act it out and to get your shot first
with that puppet that make sure it
double make sure that your shot is going
to work with the CG on top of giving you
great animation reference and acting
reference for them to practice the
rhythms and the beats and all that kind
of stuff and the crazy thing is like the
show's quality and CG animals never
falters it's always at this level for
all episodes
there we go polar bears Wow I mean the
things that stand out to me you can see
the skin underneath the fur like between
the cracks that you see the dirt you can
see different tonality to the fur like
this parts that are brown this part
white there's parts that muddy
like there's parts that are heavy
because they're wet
[Music]
wait I recognize them where do I
recognize him from that's what no way
that's Dudley that's John Lee how is
that Dudley grew up wait are they trying
to kill the bear yeah but they're just
shooting in the armor you just pulling a
Leo DiCaprio right now yeah honestly
this looks as good if not better than
the bear from the revenant I still can't
get over that that's Dudley weird things
I merely stand out to me is like the mud
treating like the physics and the fur
difference like the muddy fur mousse a
little different the other fur like the
muscles rippling underneath the fur yeah
anytime you're doing CG animals or
anything it's a several step process you
basically start with a skeleton and then
you simulate all the muscles and how the
muscles move because that's gonna
influence how the skin around those
muscles will move and then that's gonna
influence how the hair on the skin is
gonna move it's so many different layers
that are all affected by the previous
layer all the soft body stuff like the
lips and the jowls and stuff moving like
that's so hard to deal with because you
can you can't quite animate it it has to
also be physics simulation the armor not
clipping through the bear I feel like
that is some detail high-end work yeah
totally when you're doing a hair
simulation or a first emulation for that
matter you don't have every single hair
as something can edit in the program you
have guide hairs basically it comes time
to render that guide hairs and have
duplicated and then there's a little
duplicated hair some blend between guide
hairs so if you have one guide hair here
and one guide hair here the little extra
hairs are added by the renderer well bit
Duke and they'll kind of be a transition
point between those guide hairs so
you're doing physics those physics are
usually only applied to the guide hairs
and all the like the field in hair just
follows those guide hairs here you gotta
make sure that none of those familiar
hairs are poking through the armor and
just sticking through it you know like
look at the tuft on his left eye there
and it's like the tuft is like pushed up
against the armor that's nuts
did you guys ever watch The Golden
Compass movie no no and they have the
polar bears in that movie too yeah they
do let's look at the polar bears from
Golden Compass real quick
Wow already it's like this looks like a
ps2 animation it's like the coca-cola
bear commercial yeah company if you use
the same people who did the coca-cola it
looks like the same people that did the
coca-cola bears granted this movie is
also 13 years old now 14 year old
effects
yeah they move really fast
they move like they're just little tiny
bears the Bears are also just like way
more smooth you know they're way
smoother smoother or more smooth I'm not
sure I mean the first simulation is
basically what's come the farthest yeah
I mean obviously the lighting and the
surfaces is important but the first
simulation like letting you have the
clumps and letting you have the
different physics of it and letting you
have the different lengths of hair also
the clear difference right now is that
one is a CG environment and that's a
very real environment yeah yeah so the
budget for this movie was a hundred and
eighty million dollars in 2007 whoa
that's pretty high yeah there's a very
expensive movie even at the time and
yeah the budget for His Dark Materials
is about seven million dollars per
episode so you know a third of the
budget for this movie for His Dark
Materials because it's like as
technology gets better it also gets
cheaper it is crazy how much of a
downgrade this is I think more
accurately it's how far we've come in
the last 13 years yeah visual effects
it sounds like I'm just talking crap
about the VFX artist and I don't mean to
be it's more yeah like the rendering
technology has come so far hey I saw
what you just did you hit the subscribe
button thank you
oh wow what's he got on his head
Millie I wish I was a telepathic gorilla
Wow wait what whoa Wow
I feel like if you transform into a
scary animal you have to roar into
camera
yeah like guaranteed that's gonna happen
it's pretty good this CG looks really
good actually
I don't understand what is going on here
who's the good guy who's the bad guy
here is this shark actually the good guy
so the gorilla was the bad guy I feel
like I'm just more confused now the
animations may be just a little stiff
and the camera works a little stiff yeah
I totally get why like I'm giving a
little bit of pass like for being a TV
show yeah
like the he's not obeying through the
gravity at all oh I thought this gorilla
was huge well look at that slo-mo shot
breaking yeah like this looks pretty
solving being 100% CG it's something
like good video games cinematic level
that was so J that was really janky it
was so janky it disappears and what
nobody ever say yeah they're definitely
like running out of time for motion blur
whoa that freaking like 720p texture on
the guerrillas back there the dilling
set themselves up for a challenge to
also make it rain all of a sudden
[Music]
I do like the light trails that they
have in the show wait so does this show
just all about someone saying like if I
run fast enough I can fix things I can
make things right if I run fast enough
I'll get it done in a flash I'll get it
done in a flash it's for interesting
it's it's subtle but you can you can see
where the time makes a difference the
rendering technology is looking good the
Lighting's looking good but you can see
how the time affects like the animation
and the shot choice you guys ever see
beast wars oh yeah I can't help but see
Optimus Primal here beast wars is on at
exactly the time I would be eating
breakfast every day can you see some
beast wars real quick just for
comparison cuz they landed on earth
millions of years ago and then that the
things scanned fossils in the ground and
that's what they became velociraptors
and gorillas we're talking about beast
wars this is a beast wars I've got a
freakin rat trap here this is what class
is all about call me red rip its rat
trap
oh wow across the galaxy it just come to
this Optimus Primal face to face this
face look at his face is like
permanently fixed like that oh my god
have you anything to say
I'd say that's prime on dude low poly
Joe Rogan yeah and and
dimethyltryptamine which is the active
ingredient NIDA Wasco dude his nostrils
are just bowls - yeah all bowls they
don't go in
[Applause]
imagine that coming at you imagine no
shadows no motion blur here's the thing
when you don't have shadows it's really
tough to show a volume in form don't
forget this show had a very small team
working on it and it was an entirely
animated show parts of it expose
yeah
this is just like that scene in King
Kong where do you think they got the
idea for King Kong
let's go the spiders like entire face to
form so that I could look different
directions I'm Bert yeah this is like
what mid-90s late 90s yeah I will say
like first time the CG is excellent like
the animation is here the spirit like
the storytelling the character it's
doing the job it has to do and it
doesn't look that bad look how
expressive they are that rhinoceros was
disappointed and sad and I could read it
in his rhinoceros eyes I can't believe
we actually started talking about Beast
Wars on this show well that was a pretty
fun scene to watch maybe a little Jake
here and there but you know what we
wouldn't have had that scene if it
weren't for your guys's great
suggestions so please leave a comment
below as to what scenes you would like
us to react to next
now I can't hear you no I'm not coming
home no not right now because it's crazy
over there hey listen are you trying to
work from home and you got kids
screaming and you got neighbors mowing
their lawn and you got mother-in-law's
trying to talk to you in a language that
you don't understand well that's what
it's like being at my house so I came
here to the studio and I got to say that
this brand integration could not have
come at a better time the Bose
headphones 700 have arrived here and
they've pretty much saved my life
because with these headphones I can
cancel the noise around me you can put
these on and they're just picking up
your voice and not picking up everything
around you and that's a good thing when
I'm trying to get work done here I can
cancel the honey why are you out here
daddy you're just way out
not only do these headphones have
superior noise canceling but they also
come with superior quality and for
microphones which help isolate your
voice and cancel out the noises around
you so when I'm surrounded by my
annoying family and I'm going to be able
to focus on the symphony of beautiful
sound coming out of these headphones
another thing that comes in handy when
you're surrounded by crazy people at
your house is touch controls now with
the touch of my hand I can easily take
calls and call and I have the other hand
free to like hold on the kids or like
help carry something will reach up high
and get something because that's what I
do I'm just a ladder that's all I am and
if all those designs and features
weren't enough for you these headphones
also come standard with connectivity to
all your favorite voices systems now I
know what you're thinking Jake I don't
believe you because everything you say
is a brand integration on this channel
well that might be true but check out
what these other guys from the studio
have to say about it they're the best
noise cancelling headphones I've
personally ever used when you need to
dive in and have laser focus for an edit
this is exactly what you want my
favorite part about the Bose headphones
700 model is the microphone quality
since we're working at home these days a
lot of us are talking through phone
calls and video chats it helps those
calls running smoothly and my voice
coming through crystal-clear I used to
use the wire and both of them as kids
and headphones which were great but the
new 700 model has even better sound
quality and the noise cancelling really
helps me focus wow I think I can go home
now but before I go headin over to Bose
dot live slash corridor crew to find out
more about these awesome headphones
seriously if you guys are working
professionals working from home right
now these are gonna be some essential
tools they're gonna help you out quite a
bit so huge thanks to boats for
sponsoring this video
remember that's Bose dot live slash Cora
crew or just click the link in the
description below
[Music]
honey I'm coming home thank you for
watching everyone these are crazy times
we will continue to try and record these
as safely as we can we've officially run
out of our backlog so we're now doing
these it's important to these times to
still have some fun while being
responsible obviously so if you haven't
left a comment already please do but
also please hit that like button on
these videos that helps more people see
them and expand our horizons we'll see
you guys in the next one